boa noite pessoal momento enquanto eu
aprendo a mexer nisso só segundo
vamos lá então a sociedade reflexiva
muito bonita palestra do padre mas eu
acho que a sociedade é flexível e se ela
começa em pequena escala quando cada um
de nós resolve fazer uma auto reflexão o
que eu vim contar pra vocês aqui hoje é
um pouquinho de como eu tirei esse tempo
de como eu precisei dessa pausa para que
eu fizesse a minha reflexão sobre o que
eu queria na minha vida e eu começa
justamente com essa pergunta que tirou o
meu sono durante meses que é qual o
propósito da minha vida já tiraram 15
minutinhos o intervalo de almoço do
trabalho pra pensar pra quê porque a
gente está nesse mundo
qual é o meu papel enquanto pessoa
enquanto mulher e enquanto estudante
enquanto profissional que eu tô fazendo
pelo mundo que é porque a minha vida
significativa de um modo geral
e aí eu fui em busca de respostas mas
antes disso tudo
mas antes disso tudo pra gente é pra
frente a gente precisa dar um passo é
olhar pra trás
não vou contar brevemente um pouquinho
sobre quem eu era eu gosto de chamá
antiga úrsula e a ufla aqui tá falando
com vocês agora
então eu nasci em 13 isso e eu me mudei
para vassouras com seis anos eu fiquei
dez anos vassouras nilton acabou
lembrando bastante da minha vida em
vassouras é uma cidade bem pequenininha
que perto de resende e a minha vida ela
sempre por ela foi de derrubar barreiras
e gosta de dizer assim
isso foi bom que me tornou uma mulher
forte mas por exemplo eu estudei em
excelentes escolas e eu era bolsista
lá em casa a minha mãe sempre sustentei
meus irmãos e meus irmãos somos três
sozinha então ela tinha conosco um
compromisso eu vou batalhar com vocês
mas eu preciso que você me ajuda então o
meu compromisso de volta com ela era
tirar excelentes notas e isso me
proporcionou isso dá excelentes escolas
conhecer excelentes profissionais e
professores me orientar muito bem
justamente pela questão do mérito da
questão de tirar boas notas
eu jogava bola e também e eu acredito
muito que o esporte tem um papel
fundamental na vida de crianças e
adolescentes porque ele desenvolve a
cooperação eo trabalho em equipe
a empatia e cheguei ao ensino médio e no
ensino médio
me contaram uma coisa existe uma receita
para o sucesso o fla
olha você vai estudar muito vai
trabalhar e eu sei fazer uma boa
faculdade vai juntar muito dinheiro aí
você vai ter uma família um carro uma
casa e você vai poder viajar uma vez por
ano nas suas férias coordena abençoe que
seu marido de beleza vou pegar essa
receita pronta de felicidade falei vou
buscar
eu vou correr vou fazer uma boa
faculdade e aí eu dei o primeiro passo
fui para a faculdade e cheguei aqui foi
o momento que a gente estava de mudança
meus pais se divorciaram ea minha mãe
arrumou emprego aqui em resende e ao
falou só tem uma faculdade lá faculdade
dom bosco
eu acho que tem um curso que você queria
que era comunicação e eu fui pesquisar a
grade conversei com algumas pessoas
falei é isso é isso que eu quero eu
estava um pouco em dúvida no momento de
vestibular sobre qual carreira seguir
vestibular para engenharia para a
administração e para a comunicação
mas numa análise mas positivista vi que
o meu estilo de personalidade como da
combinava mais com a comunicação
e aí vim pra cá cheio de sonhos planos
vamos ver como é que é primeira primeira
experiência universitária a gente nunca
esquece alguns a primeira de outras
a minha primeira e espero que continue a
primeira e aí eu me deparei com grande
choque porque uma cidade pequena
você é tratado como especial se você se
destaca
você é tratado como diferente da maioria
chega aqui e vi pessoas excelentes o que
faziam pessoas que se destacaram
naturalmente isso me tirou da minha zona
de conforto e obrigou a descer do
pedestal que eu tinha me colocado porque
eu vinha de uma cidade menor e falar eu
sou igual a todo mundo aqui o que eu vou
fazer para poder tentar ser tão bom
quanto eles e eu comecei a trabalhar no
meu segundo ano de faculdade tive esse
contato com o mercado e eu acho que ele
foi muito importante para definir quem
eu sou hoje
depois de três anos e meio trabalhando é
eu comecei a me sentir um pouco
descontente com a minha escolha
e aí eu já não tinha mais tão palpável
na minha frente as razões
lá atrás pelas quais eu escolhi o curso
de comunicação ou mesmo porque eu
permanecer em resende bicho que por
exemplo os meus amigos ficaram em
vassouras a minha vida praticamente
ficou uma sombra um das férias nessa
mudança
e aí eu comecei a me questionar porque
eu tô aqui porque escolhi comunicação
que eu vou fazer com isso essa área
mesmo que eu quero trabalhar e aí eu
entrei nesse meio de dúvidas e isso
desmotiva muito você começa a acordar e
não de propósito em gastar o seu dia nem
que seja no trabalho eu tinha uma uma
rotina muito puxada que eu saia de casa
8 horas da manhã e voltava às 11
emendava trabalho com faculdade e final
de semana tinha pra fazer trabalho de
faculdade
eu tinha que me virar e acaba que esse
desgaste também te põe em dúvida da sua
real capacidade de seguir em frente e aí
no terceiro ano no final do terceiro ano
eu fui num congresso de neuromarketing
porque não conhece área que curiosa e
quando cheguei lá eu conheci um outro
lado da minha profissão que eu não
conhecia eu conheci pessoas que
trabalhavam com pesquisa aplicada
propriamente dita professores
universitários e aí aquilo me apresentou
uma nova possibilidade dentro da área
que tinha escolhido
e aí eu voltei cheio de idéias que ele
não isso é muito bacana eu preciso
propagar e isso eu virei quase a
propagador oficial da neurociência na
eb1 e fui muito bem recebido aqui
obviamente e eu falei olha eu quero para
a minha vida me apaixonei por isso que
eu vou fazer o que eu posso aproveitar
dessa área que eu descobri que eu gostei
na minha vida e no último ano é todo
mundo tem obrigação de fazer um trabalho
de conclusão de curso e eu falei vou
lançar esse desafio pra mim mesmo de a
batalha e tanto não vou morrer na praia
agora
e aí eu resolvi eu vou desenvolver uma
monografia dentro da área de
neurociência aplicada ea pesquisa em
alguns temas sobre coisas que eu poderia
fazer esse link com a comunicação eu
cheguei em neurociência aplicada ao
comportamento do consumo e foi um
trabalho muito complexo de fazer
primeiro porque eu não aprendi nada
disso na faculdade eu aprendi a fazer
propaganda fazer pesquisa de mercado não
aprende sobre os cérebros da faculdade
mas uma coisa que eu tenho de tirar o
chapéu foi todo o incentivo e ajuda que
eu tive de brilhantes profissionais que
eu conheci
ao longo desse percurso inclusive aqui
dentro da mpb e também em outras
universidades ea gente percebe quando a
gente tem vontade de fazer alguma coisa
às pessoas elas começam a abrir portas
para você
a vontade a gente falando em palavra
atitude à vontade ela também tem uma
força muito grande na vida das pessoas e
em busca de se auto conhecimento e
resolvi fazer um coaching de carreira
que ainda não nunca tinha ouvido falar
ou de repente ver com outros olhares eu
digo
um fator primordial para eu afirmar que
eu sou hoje foi esse corte de carreira
eu acredito que quando a gente está
perdido aquilo que a gente tem que fazer
é pedir ajuda é ser humilde falar eu não
sei como dar o próximo passo que eu faço
é esse coaching tinha um modo chamado
autoconhecimento e aí que o bicho pegou
a gente vive tanto no automático acorda
leva os filhos vai trabalhar mas vai
procurar vai para academia enfim que a
gente não tira cinco minutos da nossa
vida é para pensar eu também me saúde
está boa
eu tenho ido ao médico eu estou me
alimentando bem e eu preciso dormir mais
então esses cinco minutinhos que a gente
dedica gente que numa larga escala em
anos nos torna mais forte nos torna mais
motivados com a bíblia mais positivos
nesse coaching é ficou claro pra mim
também o que me incomodava em termos de
carreira porque também é muito prático a
gente sentar com para crise culpar
qualquer que seja um fator externo e
esquecer da nossa responsabilidade
a nossa vida não falei porque eu ponho
insatisfeita com a minha escolha
profissional que está por trás disso
e aí por meio desse desse programa eu
descobri o seguinte a comunicação ela
não e atendia em termos de valores
pessoais que cada um de nós pela nossa
criação mas temos valores
alguns são mais liberais alguns são mais
tradicionais alguns peçam pelo dinheiro
outros peço pela família outras pessoas
prezam pelo aprendizado cada um aqui que
está sentado hoje tem algum valor
preponderante
e aí quando você se propõe acordar e
ficar oito horas por dia fazendo algo
desalinhada com os seus valores
aí você começa a adoecer e é bom você
acordar antes que seja tarde demais e eu
fui eu busquei ajuda acordei e vim aqui
pra falar com vocês hoje do que eu
descobri que eu fiz uma descoberta
incrível eu vou compartilhar com vocês
o sucesso é uma coisa extremamente
subjetiva
aonde você está sentado aqui hoje busca
alguma coisa diferente
só que o ser humano tem o péssimo hábito
de achar que o que dá certo pra mim vai
dar certo para todo mundo então as
pessoas tentam colocar uma idéia de
felicidade na sua cabeça uma idéia de
objetivos na sua cabeça que não é sua e
você só consegue saber o que é melhor
pra você quando você tira esse momento
para se conhecer e olha não é uma
jornada fácil
o autoconhecimento eu digo que é um dos
processos mais dolorosos que a gente faz
não em termos de dor física mas em
termos de dor psicológica porque ele
compete e você abrir mão de quem você
era e você abrir mão de quem você achou
que você seria
e você conhecer e reconhecer essa pessoa
que você está se tornando o que você
deseja se tornar então pra mim
o que fez diferença na minha vida e eu
digo 14 empregos que eu tive quatro anos
o meu fator motivacional para mudar não
foi como eu achei que seria 18 anos o
dinheiro eu achei sinceramente que levar
uma vida pautada por dinheiro então e
pagando mais eu vou não me pagam o
suficiente a deus e quando fui trabalhar
eu percebi que não era assim quando
aceitei eu recusei uma vaga eu estava
visando um pouco mais até porque eu já
saí do emprego para ganhar - em outro
emprego e eu parei que não cair nessas
vagas o que essa empresa estava
oferecendo o que é que eu estava não me
oferecia e cheguei à conclusão que a
receita para o meu sucesso é o
aprendizado que acorda todo dia e passou
oito horas do meu dia eu sinto que eu
não estou avançando que está ocorrendo
não saiu do lugar que eu não aprendi
nada eu sinto como se a minha vida fosse
uma completa inutilidade
essa minha receita do sucesso
então quem quer quem é essa nova eu essa
nova é uma pessoa que despertou um
ambiente coletivo a gente é ensinado
desde pequena que a gente tem que cuidar
do nosso é prover pelo nosso e se
preocupar só com a gente na verdade não
é isso
nós somos uma sociedade ea sociedade
assim feita de cada um
só que cada um só olhar para si a gente
não tem ninguém olhando pra todos e se
cada um olhar para o outro tem sempre
alguém olhando pra mim e quando você
decidiu que você quer para sua vida se
torna quase que natural coisas ocorrerem
na sua vida em consequência isso porque
você aprende a focar nas coisas que você
deseja verdadeiramente e no meio desse
desse percurso até pelo congresso que eu
fui eu descobri e redescobrir e me
apaixonei pela carreira de cientista
carreira dentro da ciência o que eu
percebi que seria uma oportunidade de eu
poder produzir coisas que efetivamente
mudariam pequena ou grande escala a vida
das pessoas
eu acho que não só na carreira de
ciência mas também na nossa vida em si o
que a gente deve buscar é tentar fazer a
diferença nesse mundo e tentar fazer a
diferença na vida do outro porque uma
vez que a gente contamina o outro com
palavras boas com atitudes boas a gente
de certa forma está fazendo a diferença
na vida de alguém por exemplo uma
oportunidade que eu tive recentemente
duas semanas atrás eu tive a
oportunidade de conhecer a universidade
harvard nos estados unidos e sempre foi
um sonho para mim até para dar tamanha
importância da educação não conhecia
grande universidades do mundo não só de
fora mas de dentro também conhece a usp
foi um grande sonho da minha vida e está
perto de pessoas que acordam todo dia e
tentam fazer deste mundo a um lugar
melhor se tornou uma verdadeira
inspiração em um mantra pra mim eu acho
que é algo que eu gostaria de deixar
para vocês é todo dia quando você
acordar em buscarem um propósito pra
vocês chegarem ao fim do dia
dormirem e fazerem tudo de novo amanhã e
se eu pudesse resumir tudo isso que eu
falei durante essa toque em uma única
frase será seria aqui do ele diz um post
polícia um post ele é um psicólogo norte
americano ele tem uma ideologia chamada
psicologia inspiracional é o seguinte eu
vou focar no desenvolvimento humano em
trabalhar se todas as suas qualidades
que quando você está bem você
consegue dar o seu melhor para o mundo e
ele falou o seguinte
pergunte a si mesmo o que é importante
então ter coragem e sabedoria para
construir a sua vida dentro da sua
resposta
muito obrigada